hallo Kraftclub ich heiße Johannes und
ich habe eine frage über ein Tourblog
und
zwar wie hat sich der til den Zahn
ausgeschlagen da steht irgendwas über
Nutella oder so ein Scheiß das würde ich
jetzt gerne mal wissen das interessiert
mich danke schon mal voraus und wir
sehen uns dann auf Hurricane auf
hur hallo Johannes das ist eine sehr
gute Frage und ich spiele mit dem Felix
zusammen in de B das ist mein Bruder der
große Bruder
ja wie auch immer
jedenfalls gibt's da diesen Effekt
natürlich auch bei uns und das ging um
Nutella beim Frühstückstisch die mir
Felix halt nicht geben wollte und habe
ich ih halt geschubst und Felix hat
vielleicht ein bisschen überreagiert es
wäre jetzt auch die Gelegenheit dass du
dich mal entschuldigen könntest
eigentlich und hat mir den Zahn
ausgeschlagen aber nicht so also das ist
die Version von meine dass wir uns
einfach um das nutellaaglas gestritten
haben so rum rum er war in Tränen nah
und dann einfach so abgerutscht ist das
selber in die Fresse gehauen hat
ausgeschlagen das ist meine Version der
Geschichte das aber nicht die wahre
Version